hi thank you every
unfortunately director
come he is
with the current political situation in
Mali which is going to be part of our
conversation today I am presenting his
lecture this is his but I agree with all
this points but that's quite easy for me
and we're talking about some of the
destruction and the cultural heritage
monuments and Timbuktu and in the Dogon
country and then also some really
amazing movements and actions by the
local populations and Molly that have
actually saved a lot of their heritage
and in the face of certain destruction
by radical groups so Molly scenes and
feels a bit of a world away from a lot
of the situations that are happening
more towards the Near East and Middle
East but you know Molly Molly itself has
been going through some political crises
since about 2012 Molly which is in West
Africa as we all know it is from the
most part the eastern half of the
country that is considered to be a hot
zone it's a no-go area for Westerners
for archaeologists for tourists
whatsoever so those are the regions of
Timbuktu Kidal Gao and moti so we're
going to be focusing a lot mostly are
most of our attention and in these
regions Molly itself is also home to
several different and diverse ethnic
groups perhaps the two best-known ethnic
groups outside amali are the touareg
which inhabit the northern part of the
country and then the Dogon which are
located sort of in the central middle
part on top of these on top of these
tall cliffs because not a lot of people
have had formal training or university
classes in West African history to spend
a moment talking about some of molly's
you know long long period of history
essentially starting you know the first
empires Empire Ghana which starts around
500 BC and this encompasses a large area
and then you have the Empire of Mali and
woke after which the country is named
and this is one of the one of the
largest empires in the ancient world in
terms of land mass and it covers a dis
entire region in this hat this is around
a 13th century ad for a brief moment the
capital molly was Timbuktu but it moved
around from time to time and then the
largest West African Empire occurring
around the fourteenth and fifteenth
centuries ad was the Songo empire based
out of Gao which is a really important
city as well just as important as
Timbuktu but not as well known outside
Molly so obviously there is a lot of
trans-saharan trade that's where the
cities like Timbuktu kind of gained
prominence is due to the slavery is due
to the trades of slave gold and salt
during the during the Mayan Empire north
towards towards Africa so Molly has four
official world heritage sites we have
Timbuktu Jenny the Dogon country and the
tomb of a skia which is located and Gao
just to show up you know so we're
talking about Jenny Timbuktu and Gao
those are the three primary sort of
ancient cities and Molly Bamako is the
modern capital it really wasn't much of
a settlement until the later period and
then this is the pays dogon or the Dogon
country this location here so
effectively from Dogon all the way up
that that area has now been affected by
the current political crisis Timbuktu is
famous for a lot of things in fact the
whole city is a world heritage site if
perhaps most famous in some ways for us
three mosques which also served as a
sort of proto sort of center for for
study in learning and then also Timbuktu
is also very famous various manuscripts
for for its music very famous African
musician Ali sohcahtoa came from the
timbuk2 region and many other things
Jenny which is a sister city to Timbuktu
equally as important has a deep
archeological history as well and is
most famous for its mud masks at Jenny
and then it pays dogon the Dogon are
perhaps most famous for actually
building their settlements on the sides
of cliffs this is more of a
historical trend that has continued on
to some degree in the modern period but
essentially they build their their
settlements on the sides of cliffs
sometimes only accessible by rope and
this is a typical shrine you might see
in the Dogon country ok and the tomb of
a scale which is important islamic
monument and gow the situation in mali
now we covered sort of some of the
earlier periods but the situation in
Mali really kind of starts to heat up or
in 2012 essentially Timbuktu is the
powder keg moment here we have several
different ethnic groups are several
different radical groups kind of vying
for foreign competition sometimes in
cooperation with each other essentially
come in to Timbuktu kick out the
military and then begin a program of
total destruction of certain types of
objects so now the occupation is
currently like I said in these four
regions they've instituted certain
fundamentalist laws like Sharia law and
have had a major negative impact I mean
total impact on tourism in this area
which had accounted for about sixty
percent of revenue in these regions so
in Timbuktu this is just part of the
destruction that was recorded there but
sixteen mausoleum to early Islamic
saints were destroyed within a few days
of each other certain ritual festivals
non-islamic festivals had been stopped
even music was outlawed and in timbuktu
in mali in general and West Africa in
general music is a real cultural you
know strength of theirs and they take a
lot of pride in it so that's that's
another thing that was outlawed women
were forced to wear veils and then
perhaps the bit of information or the
act that got the most press attention
was the burning of the manuscripts and
Molly and Timbuktu so and this is just
what one of the tombs looks like that
had been destroyed okay this isn't
Timbuktu now one of the one that one of
the points that
that mr. Sesay brings up which i think
is really important and something that
we often overlook when we have these
discussions is that cultural heritage is
a wide topic it just not only covers
archaeological artifacts but effect does
cover what's called living heritage so
traditional lifeways practices ritual
song and dance all these have been in
certain regions of northern Mali have
been completely outlawed and this is
having a real negative impact not just
on the economic sort of pocket book of
the populations there due to the lack of
tourism but their own real you know but
sort of tangible aspects up there of
their living heritage has also been
diminished and you know the longer that
this goes on it's been three years now
the longer this goes on the more we at
risk of losing these really rich and
important sort of living heritage
practices so I want to bring that up
just as for some of us to you know think
about and I was good on dr. CCA to to
mention that okay the burning of the
manuscripts which in everyone wants to
know about this effectively when the
French force is well even before the
French forces came in but during the
occupation of timbuktu by these radical
groups all of a sudden there are news
pieces coming out saying that you know
all the manuscripts had been burned
which was a real shock everyone who had
heard that that piece of early news then
reports started coming out that well you
know 4,000 around 4,000 maybe had been
destroyed but Timbuktu houses somewhere
between four hundred thousand and maybe
a million manuscripts and then winter
and then when the first news crews got
into the libraries of Timbuktu and
looked around all the books were gone
and you know it was a big surprise to a
lot of Westerners and even to some
people in the mall in government but
what was most important about this story
is that it all the manuscripts were
taken away literally book by book on the
back of mopeds and boats all the way to
Bamako the capital slowly over the
course of a few months as the local
populations in Timbuktu realized that
something was going to happen and this
isn't the first time that Timbuktu has
been taken over
or conquered this is about the fourth
time the past 120 years that Timbuktu
has has seen some really serious
conflict in the same sort of cultural
institution has been enacted every time
locals go out they take manuscripts they
hide them in the desert and their
villages or they bring them to a city
that's going to be safe and then once
the situation resolves itself they'd
bring in manuscripts back to Timbuktu so
this is a really good local way of
solving this problem of how do you
protect at least heritage that can be
moved these physical books right um and
then you know I don't want take up too
much more time but you know in the Dogon
country things are looking very good as
well you have several types of sites
that have been damaged and effectively
as I mentioned before this is a major
reduction in tourism revenue for it for
this area and that now they've been now
there are knuckle traffickers in the
region and its peak in it continues to
be unstable which is unfortunate and
here you see an adult one of these one
of these doggone cliff villages this is
very recent as well you have structures
these ancient village structures before
and then just a few months later you
have you have an after photo showing a
lot of destruction so you know what do
we need to do to help protect some of
the cultural heritage I mean the answer
is simple and difficult to implement we
need to stop the political situation in
northern Mali now as archeologists and
researchers and concerned citizens of
the world you know it may not be easy
for us to manage that but what we can do
at which I think we'll have a great
benefit and which some organizations
have have already started is to help
support the local populations in their
own ways that they have developed to
help their own cultural heritage and so
right now like we said around four
hundred thousand manuscripts are being
housed in Bamako however in Bamako
there's not the funds that actually
how's the manuscripts in a way that will
them that will keep them okay so now
we're done that's it